- On this episode,
we do a call-in show.
(dial tone)
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 200
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
It's a very special episode,
Staphon, show the
characters around.
Couple more peeps in the house.
India, of course.
Brittany is in the house.
Andrew's got the info.
(laughter)
DRock on Facebook Live and
Andy on Google 360 video live.
- [India] Woo!
- Oh, very nice, India.
India is excited.
Episode 200.
We decided episode 100
show a clip from it.
Staphon, put it over here.
Episode 100 we actually brought
a lot of you together
we did a live show.
Episode 200 we're doing a call
and show so DRock why don't you
show everybody on
Facebook the phone number.
That's right, 949-427-9833.
Call The #AskGaryVee Show and
get your question answered.
India, are you
ready for the call in
- [Both] Show?
- I was super ready.
- And India why don't you
give everybody in the
Vayner Nation an update?
You've now been one of my
two assistants for the
last three weeks or so.
- Oh wow. Three weeks.
- Well, I'm asking you.
That was a question.
- I don't know.
It's flown by.
- So what you think.
Give everybody the things that
you're allowed to say,
what's the biggest surprise so far?
- The biggest surprise--
- I mean you've been
so close the ecosystem.
- Yes.
- You've been at
Vayner for how long?
Four years?
- Almost 4 years.
- Almost 4 years so
you've been at Vayner.
You've been on team GaryVee for?
- A year and a half.
- Right.
And now you're in it.
- I'm in it.
- Your closer than ever, right?
- Mhmmm.
- So what is the
biggest surprise so far?
- He's even busier
than imaginable.
I had no idea.
- It's crazy, right?
- It's super crazy.
- It's crazy right?
- DRock probably knows a little
but I feel like being in your
inbox is like the thing
that's most eye opening.
- Even DRock I
don't think knows.
You know why?
Even though he's following me
all day in those scenarios
he can't see the parallel.
That's the part
that people don't get.
The thing that happening that
you now have access to is the
scariest shit of all.
Because while I'm doing the 10
minute meetings and the insanity
this is collecting just
enormous amounts of pressure.
- It's true. There's a lot.
It's fun.
- It is fun.
Alright, 949-427-9833.
Call in now.
I will answer.
Give it here.
What's that?
That's alright, that's fine.
Facebook Live call in
949-427-9833 with your question
and I will answer
it live on the show.
I'm excited about this call in.
Now we just sit here
and we excitingly wait for
the phone calls.
I was really impressed with
everybody waiting to call.
I'm very, very
thankful Facebook.
You know what's so funny?
So many of them are on their
phone so they have to like
what do they do?
You know what you mean?
It's so weird now.
When I used to do this live
streaming on USteam and
have people call, they were like
their desktop and they would
just pick up the phone.
Now it's
all-encompassing in one device.
So, let me just see
this one more time.
And for the 2500,
it's not working.
A lot of people
saying it's not working.
1-949-427-9833.
Do you think were getting
so many calls it broke?
Doesn't go through.
Holy crap are we getting
so many, not available.
Andy what happened
did we break it?
- [Andy] I'm looking
right now.
Lines got busy.
Exactly.
Everybody's, I think we
crashed Google voice.
Did we crash it?
(laughter)
- [Andy] We can
give them this number.
- Should we give
them this number?
- We could do that.
- Do we have any other Google
Voice numbers connected this?
- [Andy] I can try.
- Did we break Google Voice?
- [Andy] Might've.
- Why?
Because the Vayner
Nation is the best.
(laughter)
We can break anything.
This is gonna be the
best episode ever.
Hope you're
enjoying episode 200.
So was working it's
all busy signals.
Wait a minute am I like.
(dial tone)
(phone rings)
- There we go.
- [DRock] Hey!
- It was me maybe.
Holy crap I think
I figured it out.
That's interesting.
- [Phone] Call from
Gilbert Dominguez.
- Gilbert Dominguez.
- [Phone] To accept press 1.
- 1. Gilbert?
- [Gilbert] Yes.
Hey what's up, Gary?
- How are you, brother?
- [Gilbert] Pretty good,
pretty good and yourself?
- Tremendous. What is
your question?
- [Gilbert] My question is I
have an upcoming provisional
patent on a warehouse product.
I was wondering what I could
do to help prepare myself to
becoming a future business owner
or entrepreneur or what not?
- So what are you worried about?
- [Gilbert] I don't know.
What can I do?
What are some books I help
prepare myself because I'm going
to end up having to cleaning
warehouses just to get my
product out there and
I was wondering, I don't know.
I have all the stuff coming up
that I have to try to accomplish
I just need some any
type of business advice.
- Let me give you good advice
you're gonna get nothing from
reading a book.
No book's gonna
tell you what to do.
What you need to do is wrap your
head around that you have to
bleed out of your fucking
eyes and work 24/7/365.
There's no advice
that I can give you.
It's gonna be about putting
in the hard work and
learning the ropes.
I'd also give you huge advice
go ask questions to all
of your future customers.
Whoever you're going to
sell to go ask them questions.
The best way to be successful
in business is to deliver for
people what they actually want
and the best way to figure out
what they want is
to ask questions.
- [Gilbert] Can I input on this?
This prototype it has
four additional attachments
that cater to the user so
that's what I'm going off of.
- Okay.
- [Gilbert] This thing is it's,
okay, it's a dust mop.
- Okay.
- [Gilbert] And it hasn't
been altered since 1993.
So what I've done is--
- I love it.
- [Gilbert] I added four new
attachments to it and it is like
the future of dust mops.
- So listen, I don't give
a shit if it is the
future of human beings.
If the customers don't
eventually like it or care it's
not going to matter so just
because you love your dust mop
doesn't mean that
the market does.
You have to go out there
and really get people
to give a crap.
Create content, get it in to
people's hands give away some
for free, get it out there.
Got it?
- [Gilbert] Okay.
- Alright, buddy.
- [Gilbert] Thank you.
- Take care. Gilbert, alright.
See who else we got in here.
Do I keep pressing this?
What's the number?
(laughter)
949-427-9833.
Why did that work?
I don't know what I did.
- [India] Like when
you test called?
- Yeah. But now.
Okay let's see
what happens.
This is so fun.
I love it.
We just gotta get the call
mechanisms down 'cause
the call in show is,
I love this.
The call in show is super fun.
Super, super fun.
I just don't know.
Who's calling right now?
Are we still busy?
I love that we just
try shit like this.
I love that people are actually
going to watch this episode and
be like what the
hell happened here?
Facebook people here.
Why can't Gary just call me?
It's busy, it's busy.
Hmmm.
Put phone number again.
949-427-9833.
(India &amp; DRock
talking over one another)
- Yeah, it's fine but I
don't think that's happening.
I'm sure someone is calling.
- [Andy] You can
call people back.
- Should I just call people?
Should I just tell people on
Facebook to put their phone
numbers and just call.
- [DRock] No we have
their number, right?
- [Andy] I can see the numbers.
- You have the numbers?
Alright, just give me a number.
Great, alright, I'm
calling some people.
This is for you guys in episode
200 because I don't make this
boring and we haven't--
- [Andy] 914-469-8676.
- You don't know
who the person is?
- [Andy] Karen.
- Karen?
- [Andy] Kerry.
- Kerry.
- [Andy] I think so.
- This is the best.
- [Phone] Hi, it's Anthony.
- Anthony, how are you?
It's GaryVee.
- [Anthony] Gary, how are you?
So nice to hear from you.
- Great to hear--
- It's your friend Conch.
- How are you Conch?
I love Conch.
Conch, what's your
question, brother?
- [Anthony] My question is Gary
amongst all the noise from all
the Snapchats and all the tweets
and all the Facebook postings
what catches your attention?
What do you look for in value
to want to do business with
somebody or want to
connect with somebody?
- You mean all the people that
are hitting me up like just do
this with me, do that with me,
like what catches my attention?
- [Anthony] Right. You talk
a lot about Twitter video.
I got my interview with
Tony Robbins through you.
- Yep, I know.
- [Anthony] I used
twitter video, I got it.
- Yep. Yep.
- [Anthony] So trying to land
meetings and connect with people
what do you look for?
What's the value to you amongst
the thousands of snaps and
thousands of posts?
I'm really like to know
what your thoughts are.
- Unlike Tony Robbins and other
things of that nature and all
the other executives I talk so
much about getting to people and
I've helped people get to people
a la what happened for you
that I get so much of
that back at me.
You know what's
really pissing me off?
Jab, jab, jab, right hook.
The amount of people that are
doing things for me that don't
have the pure intent in mind.
They're just doing it because
they want something in return.
And then they're giving me things,
I don't want your fucking jab.
Conch, I don't want the
jabs that you want to give me.
I don't want that hat.
I didn't want it.
I think that for what I look
for is pure intent and
something that brings me
value of the moment.
For example;
Let me do something
right now in episode 200.
I'm about to send an email
internally at VaynerMedia on
Monday I'm adding a new
team member to my team
called distribution.
I want to know this is all
things we talked about maybe you
guys doing but I'm going
to go a different route.
I'm going to bring one person
and their whole job for 15 hours
a day is to get
distribution for my content.
Which means for 15 hours a day
you have to reach out 200,000
websites in the world that
I think could take DailyVee,
The #AskGaryVee Show and my
articles and want to distribute
them and use them the way the
Forbes and HuffPo and others do it.
I'm looking for
things that I need.
If somebody happened to have
been paying attention to me and
realized that distribution
mattered and tweeted out hey
GaryVee I want to do
distribution for you.
I will guarantee you that I'll
get 11,000 websites in 100 days
to distribute your content,
that would've caught my attention
because that was
something I needed.
Whatever I cared about
and I need and I see being
communicated that's
what I react to Conch.
- [Anthony] That's awesome, Gary.
Listen, I appreciate it.
So, last thing and then
I'll hang up it's all about
fundamentals picking of the
phone, doing the research,
finding out what's value,
what is valuable to you,
what I think is valuable.
- Yes. Yes.
That's right, brother.
- [Anthony] Gary,
thank you so much.
- You got it, brother.
Love you Conch. Take care.
949-427-9833 is the number.
It's so funny.
- [Andy] I'm going to try
turning off call screening.
- You're going to turn off call
screening and see what happens?
Okay. Don't worry,
I'm not scared of calls.
Give me another number.
(dial tone)
- [Andy] They're
fucking calling like crazy.
- What?
- [Andy] It's non-stop,
every second.
- Here's the key.
The number one thing we have to
do and keep calling because
I want to do Andy is I want to
remarket all of the cell phone
numbers on Facebook to
sell 'em some more books.
Just kidding.
But I do want to make
sure they see content.
- [Andy] We're going
to Lexington.
859.
- 859.
- [Andy] 321.
- 321?
- [Andy] 1378.
- 1378.
I love how these people are
going to get random calls from
other people in
the Vayner Nation. Sorry.
(phone ringing)
(laughter)
- [Phone] GaryVee,
how's it going?
- Good man, who is this?
- [Phone] This is
Chase Fairchild.
How are you doing?
- I'm doing super well.
Thanks for being
on the show. Episode 200.
Thank you so much, brother.
- [Chase] It's awesome.
I'm glad I got through.
- Yeah. What is your question?
- [Chase] My friends and I
are starting a creative agency.
- Good. I think I know thing
or two about that.
- And so while we work and
read a lot of your stuff we're
trying to get all of our
ducks in a row before we start.
We launch August 1st.
How do you think the best way
for us to get over the fear of
failing at this?
It's kinda taking a leap.
We're currently in-house
marketing department for
21 chain retail store.
- I think you guys, if you guys
are taking the leap, you guys are
rounding the troops and saying
screw this place we're going to
do our thing you've got to first
decide here the ways to do it
you do the emotional and
practical when you take a leap.
The practical is how
many of you are doing it?
- [Chase] Three.
- The three of you have to
figure out worst-case scenario
nothing goes well how long can
you survive on your savings or
you're willing to be
entrepreneurial ghetto.
Got it?
- [Chase] Yeah, got it.
- So the three of you need
to sit in a circle and you go
India, how long can you last?
And India says 18 months long.
Andrew how long can you last?
Four months.
Andy how long can you last?
Two years. We know we're only as
a strong as our weakest link.
God damn Andrew's only
got four months so
we have to talk about that.
Number one do you think that the
three of you can go without any
sales for a year?
- [Chase] Yeah.
The good thing is that we have
investors from the company that
got behind us and they're like
we kind of have a safety net
in a little bit if it fails.
- So great.
So it sounds like you created the
practical version and you just
have to make the
emotional version.
Too many people and you know
I've been talking about this
fake entrepreneurship.
If you're scared to make
the jump you still have
entrepreneurial tendencies.
You're not an entrepreneur yet.
It's why you worked at a
company in the first place.
You just got to
make the jump or not.
It's like swimming.
You either jump in the
pool and you go or you don't.
The end.
- [Chase] Yeah, definitely.
And that's my fear and when
you're starting this
its new frontier you know--
- Dude, don't be scared
nothing's gonna happen.
You can always go back
to the god damn job.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- What's gonna happen?
People are gonna make fun of you?
Your mom's gonna say you failed?
Who gives a shit.
Go try it, doesn't
work it and you go.
Don't care what other
people think,
it's the only reason
that you're scared.
- [Chase] Yep.
- Whether it is your spouse,
your partner, your child,
your mother, whoever it is
eliminate those voices,
listen to yourself
and know that if you fail you
go back into it and nothing bad
will happen but if you win
it's the greatest shit that
ever happened.
- [Chase] Hell yeah.
Awesome.
- Cool. Alright brother,
see you.
- [Chase] Thanks man.
- You're welcome.
So why are calls coming through
I'm on the line but then not?
You think they're coming through
because you did the
unblock, right?
- [Andy] That what I'm--
- That was your theory but
looks what happening
there's still not ringing.
Nine missed calls.
What you want?
Are you just jumping in
the middle of my show?
I still have seven minutes.
Why would you come in?
India what's up with the
partner in crime here?
- He's very into
checking in on you.
- She's not going to
keep this thing moving.
What you mean?
I trust that Gary's knows.
- She is. We know it's
seven minutes.
Don't come in the
middle my show, Tyler.
Alright give me a number.
- [Andy] Scott.
- Scott. What is it?
- [Andy] 410.
- 410.
- [Andy] 646.
- 646.
- [Andy] 2906.
- 2906.
DRock ask them, hey guys what
you think about the call-in
concept for
The #AskGaryVee Show?
Get a little feel.
- [Phone] Reached 410646--
- Next.
There's a delay for your answers.
I want a plus up, plus down for
The #AskGaryVee Show
being a live call-in show.
Help me out.
Give me some feedback.
There's a different
energy with this.
- [DRock] You have so
many numbers calling in.
- [Andy] 414-530-3949.
(phone ringing)
- [DRock] They love it.
- They love it, right?
- [DRock] Love it.
Love it. Love it.
- Yeah, it's better.
It's good, right?
This is it.
We're going to be
a call-in show.
India your goose is cooked.
- [India] I know.
- [Phone] Oh my god it's Gary.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
(laughter)
- Who is this?
- [Phone] This is Dante.
- Dante what's up?
- [Dante] What's up?
- Where you from Dante?
- [Dante] I'm from
Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
- Milwaukee in the house.
Are you a huge Brewers fan?
- [Dante] I'm not as
big of a Brewers fan.
I'm actually a
Baltimore Ravens fan.
- Nice. Okay. Respect.
What is your question, brother?
- [Dante] Okay, all right.
All right, I have
so many questions.
Let me think of my first one.
This is my perfect question.
I started a business not
too long ago called
Forensics Forever.
- Okay.
- I work with elementary schools
and I do workshops that are
pertinent to forensics or
speech and debate
if you're familiar with that.
- Yes, I am.
- One of the hardest things to
do is to get into the schools
and provide those workshops.
- Yes.
- Because it's like
really hard to do.
- 'Cause it's politics and
bureaucratic and god damn
principals and superintendents
that all suck and are average.
Not all of you but
the most of you.
- [Dante] I really want to
change the educational system up
so first of all let me throw a
quick plug in and say if you're
an elementary school principal,
you want to work with me,
hit me up.
- Great right hook.
- A little right hook.
And also how though how do
I get past those gatekeepers?
- Easy. Content.
Dante, the best way to
sell is to not sell.
The best way in the world to
sell is to have people come to
you instead of
you going to them.
Put out content.
Write an article on medium six
mistakes a superintendent makes.
Then post it and then spent 100
bucks on amplifying the ad in
Milwaukee in that general
area and I guarantee four
superintendents and
teachers will pass it on.
It's put out content.
Film the stuff
that you can film.
Some of it will be
private and you can't.
The answer, Dante, the full
answer is making content that's
a gateway drug to penetrate
the decision-makers
in school systems. Got it?
- [Dante] Yes.
Okay last part with this
question then, how do I do that
with no money?
- Can you write?
Can you write?
- [Dante] I'm okay.
- So I would audio because
I like the way you talk.
I would do SoundCloud posts
I would post them on
your Facebook page.
You might have one fan right now
and then I would reach out to
everybody you know and ask them
to share it in Milwaukee and
literally ghetto.
Like I used to do it.
Go to Twitter and search people
talking about your subject
matters and reply to them.
Money is a tricky thing.
Money tricks people.
People think they
think they need money.
You don't need money you
need hustle and/or money.
If you want it I don't want to
hear you fucking watching
Ravens at Monday night, well
actually you do because you do
gotta watch your football team,
but after that you gotta stay
up to 2 o'clock in the morning.
You can go to Twitter search
search the 5 mile radius of
Milwaukee and hit up anybody
talking about school issues.
You can put out content
rally up all of your friends,
all 47 people.
Your fucking auntie. I don't give
a shit and ask her to share it
and it starts. It starts.
You gotta start from the bottom.
- [Dante] Okay, okay.
Definite. Definite.
- Alright, Dante get it.
See ya. Bye.
Alright, Dante.
- [India] 130 people watching in
360 and people are asking to get
the number again.
- So YouTube 360, 949-427-9833.
How many people
on Facebook live?
Almost 4000 people.
- [DRock] 4000.
- 4000. Let's go.
Andy?
- 832.
- [Gary] 832.
- 315.
- [Gary] 315.
- [Andy] 5110.
- [Phone] Hello, please state
your name after the tone and
Google Voice will try to reach--
- They're on Google Voice too.
- [Phone] Efrain Garcia.
(phone beeps)
- Gary mother fuckin' V.
(laughter)
(phone rings)
- [Efrain] Hello? Hey guys.
(laughs)
(laughter from all)
- What's up man?
It's Gary.
(laughter)
Hello?
- [Efrain] Hello?
- It's Gary Vaynerchuk.
How are you?
- Good, I just need
to take this off.
Alright, can you hear me?
- Yeah, I can hear you.
- [Efrain] Okay great I was
hearing the feedback from
watching it and
hearing my voice.
- No worries, man.
- [Efrain] Hey guys. Efrain Garcia.
Greetings from Houston, Texas.
- Big ups Houston.
H-Town what up?
- [Efrain] I was introduced from
a friend of mine, Method 21,
that me about you guys as I was
starting up my business and
definitely has lit a
fire underneath
me so I started up Unison Industrial
Solutions. It's a sales consulting
company. I was mentoring some
kids from the University of
Houston that didn't have any
direction when they finished their
degrees so what I started doing
was introducing them to trade
shows taking them out,
taking them to some of the
networking events and
giving them a crash
course on oil and gas.
- Yep.
- [Efrain] I said man, this would
be a great business to
start to network.
- So, real quick my man.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show
so I got to ask
what's the question?
I appreciate the context and
I don't want to be a douche,
I want the question though.
I'm obsessed with the question.
- [Efrain] How do you
keep it together?
I wanted to ask suggestions
of the CRM software that you
utilize to keep everything
together so I wanted to
give you an overview.
- Yep. No, I appreciate it.
- [Efrain] Get all the pieces
together and then maybe I can do
that also be able to
white label a CRM.
- Got it so you actually want to
build a CRM for people that do
stuff like you or you want to
figure out what's the difference
between an excel sheet or Google
Doc that's free and SalesForce.
And the answer is
others probably both. Right?
Are you really saying I don't
want to do a service,
I want to build a SaaS business
and create a product?
- [Efrain] No, so we do sales
consulting for oil and gas so
I want to be able to cultivate or
a farm, teach these kids that
way they have some direction
and maybe even while they
are going to school give them
practical application of
what they're learning.
- Okay.
- [Efrain] And then give them a
crash course in oil and gas so
they have a goal in
mind for their education.
Possibly hire them.
- And so the question is how do
you organize their information
to be most efficient?
I want to make sure
I understand the question.
- [Efrain] Correct.
Keeping all the students
together, I would be able to
categorize them to find out what
they're studying engineering--
- So dude honestly
SalesForce or Google Docs.
It's not super complicated.
Those are your two plays.
- [Efrain] Okay. And what
about a white label CRM.
Do you have any
suggestions on white labeling?
- Meaning you want to create
one or who's out there
that white labels?
Like what you want to do
with the white label CRM?
I want to understand
what you're asking.
- [Efrain] With the CRM I want
to really give the students a
directory with oil and gas.
- Got it. Got it, got it.
I don't know.
But the good news is there
something way better than
The #AskGaryVee Show you
should write this down.
Got a pen paper ready?
- [Efrain] Ready.
- G-O-O-G-L--
- [Efrain] Got it.
- Got it.
When you want
information, my friends,
Google is better than me.
If you want context
I might be better.
Respect?
- [Efrain] Gotcha. Thanks man.
- Thank you.
Alright, good experiment.
One more?
- [Andy] Scott, it's the dude
you tried to call but he called
back and left a voice
mail and I just found it.
- No, I want Scott
to feel the pain.
- [Andy] Okay. I tried
for you, Scott.
- Scott, we're sorry.
Andy did the right thing.
Show Andy's face.
- It was an attempt.
- Alright, fun experiment.
I got to go.
I just want to take a few
seconds and thank all of you for
allowing me to get to episode
200. It's fun because episode
200 I think you can see a little
clunky, trying to figure it out
but there's clearly the pieces,
DRock what did you see?
That people like--
- Oh yeah.
- There's pieces, the foundation
of some sort of interesting next
chapter of The #AskGaryVee Show
where we finally get rid of,
you can show the riffraff's over
here and just get rid of them.
They're finished. Technology is
taking over them.
What's that?
- [India] I have a new job.
- You have a new job.
The inbox is more
intense than you think.
Anyway I want to thank you guys
so much for supporting this show,
supporting me watching
CNBC on the other night,
I appreciate that.
The Snapchat, the
DailyVees all that.
DRock and I are going to be
back to filming those so
that should be fun.
And thank you so much for
being part of this journey
I appreciate you tremendously.
We will be back for episode 201
shortly probably Monday, right?
- [DRock] Yep.
- It will be interesting are
we going to do live Q&amp;A are we
going to go back
to the old format?
Actually, that's the
question of the day.
Give me the direction you
would like to see
episode 200 through 300.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(beep)
- [Man] Yo!
- [Gary] What up?
- [Man] Gary, this is
Josh Easton, how are you?
- Good Josh. How are you?
- [Josh] Pretty good.
Hey man, I just noticed you're
wrapping up your show so do you
still have time for a question?
- I'm not wrapping up,
I'm finished.
- [Josh] You're finished.
- But I got good news I'm gonna
sneak in this question for you.
So?
- [Josh] Alright.
- What is it? Fast!
This has to be the fastest
question and answer all time.
Go!
- I own two businesses,
I'll keep it brief.
When do you decide if you
start a business,
I have two right now.
One of them have dropped
passion in my partners don't
really have there
drive to keep going on.
- Yep.
- [Josh] At what point do you
decide to throw in the towel and
how exactly have you ever had
any situation where you found
yourself--
- Yeah.
Yeah, I've been in a lot of
businesses where I was the
minority partner non-driver of
the business that have failed.
And the way I do it is I just
take it for a loss and
I chalk it up.
You try to sell it for whatever
scraps it's worth or sell it
back to your partners
that are running it or
you just walk away.
It is a zero. It's over.
It's done.
Or if you feel like crap but
I work seven years it's
worth real money, you sell it.
And you sell it from a
non-leveraged position which
means you get less money for
it but it's still okay because
clearly by the tone of your
voice and the fact that you know
passion for number
one you got to let go.
- [Josh] You work 90 hours a
week and it gets tough to spread
it between two places making sure
your time is in the right place.
- Yeah. The real question is how
much money are you going to lose
and are you willing to lose it?
A lot of times what people don't
realize they don't lose the
$40,000 or $5000 or $500 million
and they can make 700 million or
5000 times if you get back your
40 hours from that thing or 30
or 20 or even 10 you might make
more money deploying against a
thing you care about the
money you left on the table.
So XYZ you're leaving hundred
thousand that you're giving up
and you're like shit I
can't give that up but we don't
realize of the 18 hour backs and
happiness and not the drain and
emotional drain of the hundred
hours a week on the other thing
allows you to make
120,000 on your new gig.
- [Josh] Yeah, that's
exactly where I'm at.
How much more money can
I make of another business if
I designate more time to it?
- You know the answer.
You know the answer.
- [Josh] Yeah, yeah, no
it's totally clear now.
Never start businesses
with friends with either.
- No. Not true.
Always start businesses with
friends if you can pull it off.
- [Josh] Get everything in writing.
Listen it didn't work out.
It's a life lesson, right?
But, you know, that's
the fucking game baby.
This is entrepreneurship.
- [Josh] Yeah, I know.
- What? It is India.
- [India] No! It's the beeps!
- Oh, the beeps funny to you.
Alright I got to
go bro, I love you.
- [Josh] Alright, thanks man.
- See ya.
- [DRock] Here, your phone.
- [Phone] Call from unknown caller.
To accept press one.
(India laughing)
(upbeat hip hop music)